i know on bigger shows
that happens a lot like the csi's of the
world
directors come in and out and they don't
get a lot of time with their
cinematographers and that's that's got
to be scary that has to be very
challenging
how many times do you read a screenplay
before you step on set that's a really
good question whenever
yeah it's funny whenever i start a new
project and uh and it's you know i get
this the script
i always think i'm going to read it a
million times i think i'm going to read
it every night
and inevitably
other things come my way and i end up
not reading it as many times as i want
but that said
i read scenes so i won't read it
beginning to end that many times you
know a few times certainly right at the
beginning
um but then it really becomes
it very quickly turns into a puzzle so
it's almost like you're given the puzzle
all as a finished piece
and then almost immediately you break it
up and then it's little puzzle pieces
and you're like okay this one we're
gonna do on day 17 this one and you
almost separate it out
and so it
and so i'll read the scenes a number of
times but as a whole
i might not revisit it
again
it's very it's strange but also in tv
there are rewrites happening all the
time
so you have to reread because there are
new drafts coming and sometimes this has
not happened much but it has happened
where there's a rewrite that happens and
you're in week
nine
and there's a rewrite and
i will have missed an email or something
and i won't realize
and we'll be on set and like oh this is
where they walk out to the kitchen
you're like no no no they go to sleep i
remember this and like no no in the
rewrite now it goes you're like oh no
like i didn't and so you scramble and it
sucks when that happens but it does
happen tv and different shows you know
some shows are rewriting
as you're on set i mean pen 15
has a lot of improv which is a little
different but they will improvise
and as we're doing it they'll we'll
realize oh this affects a scene that we
have to shoot next week or this affects
a scene we've already shot
so the whole thing does need to be in my
head pretty well
so it's
i guess the answer is i never read it
enough
i always think i'm going to read it more
but it's always close i'm always if i
have a minute
especially on the day the morning of i
reread the scenes that we're shooting
for the day for sure to refresh but then
i also try to look at for every scene
that you're shooting you look to either
side of it like where did we just come
out of and then what are we going back
into because that affects your first and
last shot in a sequence too
because you want it to you don't want it
to be jarring when it cuts to the next
thing so you're trying to hold a lot in
your mind
do you take any notes or storyboard when
you're going through a script
yeah i don't storyboard when i'm reading
a script um but i do take notes i take a
lot of notes on but it's it's especially
at the beginning it's very loose it it's
whatever occurs to me like sometimes
that's an actual shot i'll write down oh
slow zoom in
or big wide or you know what whatever
whatever that is or get a close-up of
the scissors
anything whatever that for what if it
strikes me
but
um
often and sometimes it's it's something
a little broader like um oh handheld
maybe this is a handheld moment or maybe
this is static or maybe some it's rare
at the beginning but sometimes like a
color might occur to me something really
i'll let myself jot down anything and
then i'll let future me
decide if that's relevant or not but i
do take notes
um i don't storyboard and i have rarely
worked with directors who storyboard
unless it's a commercial because it's so
much smaller it's much easier
or if there's a difficult sequence
difficult can be
maybe it's an action sequence
or it's just
you know
like let's say four people in a car can
get very confusing and so sometimes
i'll have directors who will storyboard
because they want to make sure like oh
this and like that everything is kind of
intentional
but usually it's shot lists and so it'll
be a list of like you know wide medium
close-up on her we need to zoom for this
moment and it's a list
and that's kind of your guide and your
map and very often
uh that all changes on the day maybe
because an actor goes a certain way or
maybe because you have a new idea but
having that plan
goes a long way and even if you never
use a single shot
it means you know because there are
going to be days where you're not
feeling it where you're not like you're
just whatever
the actors are out of it or the
directors out of it or i'm out of it
and then you know you have something to
fall back on that will still work like
this is still going to this is this is
still a recipe that in the end you have
a scene
so i think it's really important to have
that really important to plan and talk
that out but then on the day
always being ready
for something better and or if just
something changes dramatically you lose
a location or whatever
i think being able to to improvise is
really valuable
do you come up with your own shot list
or do you always leave that up to the
director
generally the director
brings a shot list um very often we do
that together that's the ideal is that a
director and i um
the really the best what i find is is
the best way it's just generally not
practical is to be able to go with the
director to a location
and be up on your feet and actually like
walk around use the phone as a little
like take pictures we'll do that
[Music]
that is
that's the ideal
rarely do you have time to go ahead of
time with a director to a location
usually you have to pay for locations
whenever you're there so
um
but yeah generally it's with a director
you
sit through each scene and you talk it
out and you're kind of imagining
how
you know actors might move in the space
and what moments do you need
but sometimes a director will just come
with their own shot list that they've
done on their own and then i look
through it we talk through it maybe i
have suggestions really where i uh i
think one of the strengths that i have
is
on the day because you're always
battling time
is
watching the directors and actors walk
through a scene
when i can see it up on its feet
i can often figure out a way to combine
two or three shots into one like oh if
she starts here and then she walks to
there and i slide the camera here then
we'll actually get
both of those shots on your list like
that's
that's something that
i think is very helpful for time but
also
you know trying to cut down on the
number of shots just for for
you know to try and control the edit a
little bit to tell the story uh again
with intention is that it's like well
instead of just get putting the camera
here and then putting it here and
putting it here and putting it here it's
like maybe we can travel maybe this
actor's move can pull the camera and now
you're in a new setup that gets you this
other thing that you you wanted
so
but it's it's a combination for sure and
different directors some are better at
shot listings some are worse some hate
it some love it uh and so i have to be
kind of
amenable to all of that
how much do you plan out the day before
your shoot the ideal is that
every day is very well planned out uh
and
that doesn't mean it won't change
because it will change but
the ideal is that way now that said
uh
sometimes working on series
you don't get time to prep with the
directors some directors come in and
let's say they're doing episodes four
and five
and they you know you've hopefully met
them but even sometimes
you're meeting them on the day and
they're coming in and they've done their
own prep that's separate from you
and you
try to do your best to to work with them
and i know on bigger shows
that happens a lot like the csi's of the
world
directors come in and out and they don't
get a lot of time with their
cinematographers and that's that's got
to be scary that has to be very
challenging
i've been lucky enough that that's rare
for me usually i get some time with them
but
uh very often
they will a director will come in with a
plan that i have never seen before
and then i will
depending on their comfort level um i
will try and make that fit
like our location a little more or the
feel of the show because i've been
shooting it for a while so i'm like oh
normally we won't
zoom here or whatever that is
so it's yeah it varies
and it's it's
and then there are i have worked with
directors where there we just
have a good rhythm and we just kind of
wing it you know like we we show up on
the day and i'm pretty good at
if i have actors and a director and all
that i can figure out
what shots
create a scene for sure
so
but that's taken years of shooting shows
for sure but at this point i feel pretty
comfortable with that
you